Having seen an example for n equals
four, now let's state the Fast Fourier
transform precisely for
the general case.
As input, we have a sequence of numbers,
a 0 through a n minus one, or
N is a power of two, and we want to
return the values of the corresponding
polynomial at the nth roots of unity.
We'll state this as
a recursive algorithm, and
the base case is where n is equal to 1.
And in that case, we want to return
the single element sequence,
consisting just of a 0,
the constant term.
If n is greater than 1, then we call
the Fast Fourier transformer cursively.
Once with the even coefficients.
And once with the odds.
Then we combine the results,
taking care of paired values together.
Notice the difference in the sign on
the contribution from the odd powers,
which became S prime.
How long does this take?
Well, we traded one problem of size
N for two problems of size N over 2,
plus some order N work for
all the arithmetic in this loop.
By the master theorem, this gives us
a running time of order and log in.
This is much better then
the N squared running time,
from the naive evaluation by Horner's
rule or by matrix multiplication.
There's one other wrinkle that I
want to add to the algorithm, and
that is to say that this
omega parameter here,
can really be any primitive
nth root of unity.
All that matters is that all
the powers be distinct, and
that those be the roots of unity.
So we can add this as a parameter
to our algorithm as well.
We now take in as well, that omega is
a primitive nth root of unity, and
we'll use that in our
update rules in here.
We'll see how this comes in handy later.